president Trump attacks al Sharpton so
Democrats rushed to his defense the
media continued to push the Trump is
racist narrative and we preview the
Democratic debates tonight this is the
Ben Shapiro show sorry for the late
start guys but as it turns out when you
run an Internet company one of the
things that you need is internet we did
not have that but finally we have
achieved connection and now we begin
okay so the big story of today is the
continuing fight between President Trump
and pretty much everybody I think it's
fair to say at this point this was at
war with Elijah Cummings
you'll recall that over the weekend the
president went after the city of
Baltimore he said that it was rat
infested he said that it was a terrible
place to live all of that is kind of
true and everybody went nuts ah this was
obviously racist how could the president
rip into Elijah Cummings how could the
president rip into Baltimore and then
people were like oh yeah it's Baltimore
and that city is not well-run and there
were riots there like four years ago and
it has some of the highest crime rates
in America and it has tremendous pockets
of poverty and people living in absolute
penury and run-down conditions people
who are trying to splice in their home
water to fire hydrants just so that they
can live in these derelict houses so
kind of Trump's not wrong is he and then
the music no no pay no attention to that
racist racist to criticize Baltimore
racist to point out that Baltimore is
not a great place to live and doesn't
matter that Trump has said before that
New Hampshire was a drug infested n if
you used the word infestation that means
he was referring to black and brown
people and when he said that no people
want to live there he didn't mean that
people are actively moving out and that
as of the last census Baltimore had lost
population as it has been doing for
decades
no what he meant was that everyone who
lives there is not a human being and the
media painted this ridiculous narrative
okay so then the president decided to
open up his guns on another front he
decided to go after al Sharpton
so today the president tweeted out
yesterday he tweeted out quote I have
known now for 25 years this is all
because al Sharpton decided to go to
Baltimore because this is what el
Sharpton does al Sharpton is basically a
We the People concert at halftime of the
Super Bowl in 1987 basically just
parachutes right into the center of a
controversy and then he stands owner
goes give me money that is our
Sharpton's routine
he's done it for years it's a Donald
Trump tweeted out I have known elf for
25 years went to fights with him in Don
King I always got along well
he loved Trump he would ask me for
favors often L is a con man a
troublemaker always looking for a scar
the fact the President Trump does not
see the contradiction between the first
half of his statement and the other half
sake we were best friends oh so he's a
piece of crap and always has been he
continues just doing his thing must have
intimidated Comcast NBC hates whites and
cops and now it is fair to say that al
Sharpton is a con man a troublemaker
always looking for a score that is
exactly what Al Sharpton is Al Sharpton
is the worst al Sharpton is a pile of
race-baiting garbage he has been since
he jumped onto the national scene how
bad is hell Sharpton Robert F Kennedy
jr. who is no right winger once wrote in
his diary quote al Sharpton has done
more damage to the black cause than
George Wallace he has suffocated the
decent black leaders in New York his
transparent venal blackmail and
extortion schemes taint all black
leadership RFK jr. called trapped in a
buffoon who gave him the creeps
and then because Sharpton was given all
sorts of media attention then our FK jr.
backed down when the Diary became public
then he called him an extraordinary
national leader over the past decade
which is the way that all of this works
always this always works where where you
criticize people correctly and then the
media go crazy and then you back down
well Trump is not one for backing down
on all of this the reason that Sharpton
ended up with a prime-time spot on MSNBC
if you go back is that in 2011 MSNBC
president Phil Griffin decided to hire
Sharpton after Sharpton got into a spat
with Young Turks hosts chanc Eiger who
used to have a show on MSNBC and Eiger
accused Griffin of Kao telling to the
White House right and then Griffin
touted Sharpton he said I have known
Reverend Sharpton for over a decade I
have tremendous respect for him he's
always been one of our most thoughtful
and entertaining guests I'm thrilled
he's now reached a point in his career
where he's able to devote himself to
hosting a nightly show his show has
never gotten anything close to good
ratings in a second I want to talk about
exactly how al Sharpton was revitalized
in the American public eye because he
was basically out of
American public eye for a couple of
decades there because everybody knew
what a con man he was and then he was
restored to a point of glory by none
other than Barack Obama will gets it and
just saying but first president Trump he
tweeted out if the Democrats are going
to defend the radical left squad and
King Elisha's Baltimore fail it will be
a long road to 2020 I'm not sure where
he's getting the King Elijah stuff I
guess that's his new nickname for Elijah
Cummings who by the way is pretty well
respected on both sides of the aisle as
somebody who at least treats Republicans
with some modicum of decency Trump
tweeted if the Democrats are gonna
defend the radical left squad and Keeney
Lodge is Baltimore fail it will be a
long road to 2020 the good news for Dems
that they have the fake news media in
their pocket okay fact check true on
everything except for the King Elijah
thing everything else true President
Trump has a gift his gift is that no
matter what he does
Democrats will oppose it as I said
yesterday on the show I have a
three-year-old my three-year-old refuses
to eat the way that I get him to eat is
by saying to him do not eat that Donald
Trump basically does that by just saying
that he doesn't like some things he'll
be like cancer it's the worst I hate
cancer I've been fighting against cancer
my holiday and Democrats would be like
cancer how could you fight against
cancer why would you fight against
cancer cancer is the best pancreatic
stage-four cancer is the greatest
whatever Trump attacks Democrats decide
to defend and so now they are defending
now they're defending al Sharpton the
New York Times headlines all of this
this way Trump widens war on black
critics while embracing quote inner-city
pastors so obviously this is a racial
thing it's not just the Trump doesn't
like Al Sharpton and doesn't like Elijah
Cummings and this morning by the way
attacked Mika Brzezinski and Joe
Scarborough went after them brutally he
says just reminded my staff that Morning
Joe and psycho
this is his nickname for Mika Brzezinski
which is just delightful that the
presidents of the United States just
calls people psycho just reminded my
staff that morning Joe and psycho were
with me in my room at their request
denied I wonder Hampshire likewise
bothered me two other states don't watch
show but heard mica say I asked to
preside over the marriage not true does
anyone really believe that they were
married by Elijah King of Baltimore oh
okay but the last I checked minka
Brzezinski pretty white Joe Scarborough
pretty white so I'm pretty sure that is
not in fact a racial attack nonetheless
the New York Times says it's all about
Peter Baker and Maggie Haberman
reporting quote President Trump widened
his war on critics of color on Monday
with new attacks on Reverend Al Sharpton
now why is it that it's always critics
of color why doesn't how about just
critics he attack Nancy Pelosi yesterday
he attacked Joe Scarborough and Mika
Brzezinski who are both white today but
apparently Trump only attacked black
people I mean you'll you'll have to
forgive every other Republican candidate
in 2016 for thinking differently I'm old
enough to remember when Donald Trump was
attacking you know every single person
he didn't like because I'm older than
one minute ago but according to the New
York Times it's all about the color well
look at that objective news coverage
right there from the New York Times a
spectacular objective news coverage from
the New York Times I get some more of
that spectacular objective journalism
New York Times journalism in everywhere
getting their journalism everywhere I'll
get to that in one second first it is
very difficult to find sunglasses that
are quality and that lasts a while and
they don't break right off and that
don't cost you a fortune and one of the
big problems of sunglasses that you'll
buy a pair that's really expensive and
then either it does break pretty easily
or you lose it and you just spent a
fortune on sunglasses that are gone well
I have a solution for you
movement sunglasses so as you know I
have several movement watches and
they're terrific right and they're
minimalist they're good-looking they're
really durable I really like my movement
watches I my entire family has some my
wife now has Moomins sunglasses I have
two pairs of moving sunglasses and a lot
of cool looks they've got some classic
looks a 1950s style sunglasses I've got
the aviators got what you're looking for
eyewear moved in sunglasses because they
do hit that sweet spot of style quality
and affordability movement sunglasses
started 60 bucks no pair prices over 95
bucks so you're guaranteed to find a
style you love with quality that's not
gonna break the bank they've sold over
2.5 million products across more than
160 countries their collections are
always expanding get 15% off today with
free shipping and free returns by going
to MVM t-dot-com slash appear oh see why
the movement keeps growing that's MDM
t.com slash up hero join the movement
right now MVM t.com
slash ship here I love all their
products you will to really quality and
they ain't gonna cost you a fortune
MVM t-dot-com slash Shapiro okay so
according to the New York Times is all
about race of course of course it's not
just the president Trump is thin-skinned
and a bully and attacks anybody who
doesn't like know it is that President
Trump is a vicious brutal
easiest always always and then they
wonder why people on the right don't
take them seriously every time they
scream racist because this is the boy
who cried racist you keep calling racist
eventually when the wolf shows up
nobody's gonna believe you anymore but
according to the New York Times in a
third straight day of broadsides against
black figures mr. Trump denounced mr.
Sharpton on Twitter as a con man who
hates whites and cops and again a sales
representative Elijah Cummings and his
Baltimore based district drawing rebukes
from Maryland Republicans as well as
Democrats mr. Trump's determination to
intensify the furor rather than move on
guaranteed it would continue to dominate
the political debate in Washington and
force many of the president's fellow
Republicans to choose whether to stand
by him break with him or in the case of
most find a way to keep out of the
discussion the president linked the
clash with mr. Cummings to his earlier
demand that for Democratic Congress
women of color go back to their home
countries and he cast it in electoral
terms well no that's not what he did he
did not harken back to the go back to
the home country suite he just said if
the Democrats are gonna defend the squad
and Baltimore it's gonna be a long road
to 2020 that part is true now what Trump
is neglecting to mention is that while a
lot of members of his base are sort of
cheering this sort of thing on he does
have to win some suburban women that
would be a useful thing and you know
what suburban women find off putting the
president lashing out in every direction
like a caged hyena you know it's not a
good book for the President of the
United States so well what he says about
Baltimore is true and what he says about
Al Sharpton is 100% every sort of way
true is it good politics is it smart
politics I don't think so particularly
now I guess that what Trump is going for
here is that it's year and a half out
from the election and hopefully by the
time of the election things will have
died down but the quotes will remain
forever because all the Democrats came
out to defend Al Sharpton all of them
universally say he had Kamala Harris
defending Al Sharpton and she tweeted
out the reverend al who spends his life
fighting for what's right and working to
improve our nation even in the face of
hate it's shameful yet unsurprising that
trump would continue to attack those who
have done so much for our country al
Sharpton has done zero things for our
country he has done an incredible number
of horrible things for our country al
Sharpton is a blot on our republic in
terms of politics he is just the worst
okay this is a man who's involved in
inciting a pogrom
not once but twice once at Freddie's
fashion Mart and
in Crown Heights we'll go through all of
it this is a man who has injected
himself into every race debate in the
United States for the past several
decades
never to the positive this is a man who
who created one of the worst rape hoaxes
hoaxes in modern American history and
slandered a prosecutor as a rapist for
no reason other than his own
self-aggrandizement a man who has earned
his living by shaking down company after
company on the basis of false
accusations of racism and yet every
democrat is out of the woodwork
defending this guy so i guess if the
strategy here is that we'll get to use
these quotes next year in the election
and maybe it's a strategy or it could
just be that Trump is a creature of
instinct and he says whatever he feels
is on his mind at the time because
here's the problem if this were all
strategy then you would imagine that a
year from now as the election approaches
Trump would quiet it down so you really
think Trump is gonna stop this stuff
before the election or do you think that
he's just gonna continue to ratchet it
up and alienate a lot of suburban women
as I've been saying for this entire
election cycle if Trump shuts up if we
duct-tape him if President Trump
duct-tapes himself and goes down into
the basement of the White House and
watches Shark Week and stormy Daniels
pornography until the election the dude
will be president forever
if he continues to talk he will remind
people that he exists and that's a
problem because what 2016 shows is that
if it's a referendum on Democrats
Democrats lose
well 2020 what 2018 showed is if it's
run a referendum on Trump and
Republicans Republicans lose so Trump's
job now is to make this a referendum on
Democrats which requires two things
Democrats to be crazy check and Donald
Trump to not be the center of attention
jaian failed anyway the Democrats come
out in full force for Al Sharpton
Elizabeth Warren tweets out the Reverend
Al has dedicated his life to the fight
for justice for all this is so sickening
it's so sickening al Sharpton is an
unrepentant anti-semite Al Sharpton is a
racist a real racist okay I have proof
of this al Sharpton is one of the worst
public actors of our lifetime
most black folks in America do not see
al Sharpton is a true racial leader they
may see a tax on Sharpton as racially
motivated because the media have taught
everybody in the country black white and
green that any attack on somebody who is
quote-unquote a black leader even if
that black leaders a bad person like Al
Sharpton must be racially based it can't
be based on the fact that al Sharpton is
a garbage human nonetheless I don't
most black people in America when they
look for leadership look to Al Sharpton
he is a media appointed and
self-appointed
arbiter of race in the United States and
here are all the Democrats coming out to
tout him specifically we know why this
is happening right this is happening for
two reasons one to attack Trump two
because Elizabeth Warren thinks she's
gonna carve into the black vote by
touting Al Sharpton's she tweets out the
Reverend al has dedicated his life to
the fight for justice for all except for
Steven Pagonis who he accused of rape
falsely and then had his company pay up
the settlement not him personally she's
no amount of racist tweets from the man
in the white house will erase that and
we must not let them divide us I stand
with my friend al Sharpton and calling
out these ongoing attacks on people of
color does Elizabeth Warren and then Joe
Biden got into the act so Joe Biden
should know better but of course he
doesn't because Joe Biden for all the
talk about Joe Biden being moderate not
really all that moderate he's moderate
when you look at the other Democrats
which is like saying that Trotsky was
moderate compared to Lenin Joe Biden
says the Reverend L is a champion in the
fight for civil rights the fact that
President Trump continues to use the
power of the presidency to unleash
racist attacks on the people he serves
is despicable
this hate has no place in our country
it's beneath the dignity of the office
kind of ironic for all these Democrats
to be talking about the evils of hate
while touting al Sharpton
well Sharpton himself responded he went
on to you and Sharpton could not be
happier about this right mean this is
Sharpton's thing what Sharpton is
looking for is the spotlight Trump just
gave it to him basically we all now live
in New York City circa 1991 it's dawning
from the Queens versus Al Sharpton that
is what our politics has become in one
second we're gonna get to Al Sharpton's
response to president from and then I
want to go through Sharpton's record
just so you know who the Democrats are
defending today first these days a lot
of workplaces offer employees some
pretty nice perks so for example we only
chained up our employees six hours a day
we let them wander around in the yard on
their own for at least 20 minutes a day
and also we feed them gruel so there are
lots of perks here at the Daily wire
offices but for some companies they
offer people life insurance well you
might not actually be at one of those
companies you may actually need life
insurance like say you work at the Daily
wire and we train you up 6 hours a day
and may lower your life expectancy and
you're thinking to yourself I need some
life insurance well that's why you
should head over to policy genius.com
policy genius is the easy way to shop
for life insurance online in minutes you
can compare quotes from top insurers and
find the right amount of coverage at the
best possible price if you have
workplace life insurance the policy
genius team can even review that policy
and let you know what additional
coverage you might need so even if you
got life insurance through your programs
well maybe you need more life insurance
because he'll your life is worth more
than those five bucks your employer was
willing to pay for
so remember workplace life insurance
policies are like workplace and acts
better than nothing but not quite enough
head on over to policy genius.com today
find out how to supplement your
workplace life insurance and better
protect your family policy genius it's
like a buffet made of life insurance
which is important may not be all that
filling to your stomach but it is really
good for you what could be more
delicious than that
besides cake well I mean also but mostly
just useful I mean you're like you need
life insurance go to policy genius
Connor I just do it be a responsible
adult policy genius.com case al sharpton
comes out in defense of himself because
that's what l sharpton does best and he
says I am I'm a a warrior a warrior for
truth a warrior here he is we've got to
change our target where we start
challenging the Republicans particularly
those up for Senate races this year that
you are going to stand up and really
deal with the head of your party Donald
Trump or you're the one that's going to
suffer the consequences and and make him
look to his own base inconsistent for
you that to go after the senators and
the Republican leadership that have
large ideas while he's peddling racism
and dividing this country we're ending
here my favorite thing is that al
Sharpton keeps tweeting out pictures of
himself with Trump and from keep saying
I'm like best friends with Sharpton and
we hate each other it's hilarious it's
hilarious because they did they walked
in the same circles in New York City
al Sharpton tweeted out he put out on
Instagram actually a photo of himself he
said this is a 2006 photo of Donald
Trump at the National Action Network
convention in New York in the photo he's
telling the Godfather of Soul James
Brown and Reverend Jesse Jackson why
despite the fact I marched on him
throughout the years he respected my
work now I'm a conman and troublemaker
that's why he came to my events you're
right mr. president
I'm gonna keep making good trouble
against racism and people like you that
normalize it but you're like in a photo
with him you had him at your event so on
the one hand you have Trump going out
sharpens the worst also we used to hang
out together
all the time and on the other hand
you've al sharpton going Donald Trump is
a racist and brutal and also we used to
hang out together all the time
what in the world also I I will note
here that Joe Scarborough sponsored a
resolution condemning Al Sharpton back
in the 1990s for exactly the race baiter
and con man he has now Joe Scarborough
touts that dear friends what has changed
about how Sharpton the answer is
absolutely nothing absolutely nothing
has changed about Al Sharpton
nonetheless you have Sharpton on the
rampage saying what Trump is doing here
would make George Wallace blush really
really we've heard the George Wallace
comparison a lot with regard to
President Trump I don't like a lot of
president Trump's racial language I've
condemned it when he says something that
I think is bad but George Wallace maybe
should spare the comparisons of a
president to George Wallace for the
people who stand in school school door
houses right that the schoolhouse doors
the doorways blocking it and say
segregation now segregation today
segregation forever maybe you should
save the comparisons to people who are
like forcibly in favor of
state-sponsored segregation not for a
dude who mouths off as though he's a
talk radio caller maybe that but al
Sharpton says no no he's just like
George Wallace a consistent pattern and
a deliberate political strategy that
would make George Wallace blush with
this president's doing I remember as a
kid I just become youth director of
operation breadbasket in New York George
Wallace ran in 68 George Wallace didn't
do some of the things that that in the
campaign right George was a terrible guy
stood in the door the University of
Alabama but in the campaign he tried to
dress it up more than what we're seeing
this president well you know Kevin no
she's really not actually he's a George
Wallace again segregation yesterday
segregation today segregation forever no
and as far as people who are racially
divisive I'm sorry Donald Trump does not
come close to a Sharpton he does not now
let's go through our Sharpton's record
since he is apparently a person of
justice and wonder
according to MSNBC and NBC News
apparently he is a person who has fought
for justice for all according to
Elizabeth Warren he's a person who is a
good friend of Joe Biden and Kamala
Harris hey al Sharpton is one of the
most despicable people in American
public life and has been for years I
used to run an organization called truth
revolt it was specifically designed as a
counter to media matters so maybe
is a horrible left-wing organization and
all they do is they spend their days
listening to conservative shows and then
trying to drive boycotts against
advertisers on conservative shows even
if those advertisers don't endorse the
message they just want access to the
audience and the advertisers advertise
on a range of products that's what media
matters does so we decided that we were
going to launch a counter to media
matters called truth revolts and we were
going to go after advertisers on the
left and teach the left that this tactic
can be used on both sides we called it
mutually assured destruction we said
openly we don't like the strategy but
we'll do it if you guys keep doing this
routine the first person we targeted was
Al Sharpton why because Al Sharpton is
the worst and it is inexcusable
inexcusable that MSNBC found it
necessary to put him on the air now they
can do it they're a private company and
my general perspective is if you
actually don't like Al Sharpton don't
watch his show and I'm not really going
after advertisers other than to prove to
the left that this thing can be done on
either side I said so at the time with
that said Al Sharpton is the worst he's
the worst
hey so according to Stuart Stevens over
at The Daily Beast this is circa 2017 he
goes through what el Sharpton has done
quote the Tawana Brawley case that
captivated New York in the late 80s is a
shocking reminder of the toxic mix
racial exploitation and personal
ambition can produce the New York Times
and retro report have just released a
new 15 minutes occu mentary on the
despicable host hoax which should be
required viewing for NBC news executives
are heavily invested in rehabbing a key
culprit of this loathsome episode the
Reverend Al Sharpton rally was 15 years
old in 1987 when she was found in her
hometown of weapon jur Falls New York
with KKK and the n-word written on her
stomach her jeans burnt in the crotch
feces in her hair and her tennis shoes
sliced open she said she'd been abducted
in raped by a group of white men a trio
of increasingly prominent and radical
New York City black activists
represented her and her family attorneys
alton maddox and Seaver and Mason and
Reverend Al Sharpton rally told them a
cop had been wandering for attackers
Sharpton named that officer as Harry
Chris jr. a police officer from a nearby
town who had committed suicide shortly
after Bradley was found Sharpton also
named a local prosecutor Steven Pagonis
as one of the attackers offering no
proof none none Bradley and her at her
advisors refused to cooperate in any way
with the prosecution and its team
Sharpton says
was the decision of the lawyers when
asked why Bradley's team would not meet
with New York State Attorney General
Robert Abrams Sharpton said it would be
quote like asking someone who watched
someone killed in the gas chamber to sit
down with mr. Hitler Sharpton later
accused Ryan who is the veteran
prosecutor Jack Ryan of kicking a blind
man in a scuffle with demonstrators Ryan
was nowhere near the scene after a
six-month investigation a grand jury
found the entire episode of been a hoax
Bradley had to face herself to avoid the
wrath of her stepfather after staying
out late to visit a boyfriend Sharpton
was found guilty of defamation in a
lawsuit brought by prosecutor Steven
Pagonis okay let me let me give you a
clip of just who al Sharpton was at the
time this is from Morton Downey jr. as
show and this is Morton Downey jr. on
Morton Downey jr. show this is al
Sharpton screaming and a member of the
audience that that person is a punk F
word and the F word is a is a slur for
gay people
it isn't quoted again 1987 okay I mean
that was L Sharpton and not much has
changed about Al Sharpton except that
he's gotten a little bit more subtle he
said of Assistant District Attorney
Parganas quote we stated openly Stephen
Parganas did it if we're lying sue us so
we can go into court with you and prove
you did sue us sue us right now and and
then put on his suit and he lost hey
that was just the beginning
al Sharpton also had an active role in
the Crown Heights riots of 1991 on
August 19 1991 a tragic accident left
seven-year-old Gavin Cato dead is
according to truth revolt searching for
an outlet many in the community blaze
that place to blame for the death of the
young african-american child on the
Jewish driver of the car and the Jewish
emergency responders have failed to
revive the child some discontented
members of the neighborhood proceeded to
exploit the situation by encouraging
violence culminating in deadly riots
that led to the death of Jewish
community members Yankel Rosenbaum who
was repeatedly stabbed in the back and
beaten by a group of young black men
shot and kill the Jew before as the
riots continued Sharpton yelled quote if
the Jews want to get it on
tell them to pin their yarmulkes back
and come on over to my house a few days
after the death of Rosenbaum had the
eulogy of Kate Cato's funeral and these
riots continued for day they're rolling
riots he said quote all we want is to
say what Jesus said if you offend one of
these little ones you got to pay for it
no compromise no meetings
no coffee klatch and no skin and in
grinning one banner at the rally read
quote Hitler did not do the job this is
this is who al Sharpton is this is who
al Sharpton was and didn't stop there
al Sharpton at Freddy's fashion Mart
railed against quote/unquote white
interlopers what happened there well
there was a chain a little strip mall
that was owned by a black church the
black church rented it out to a Jewish
guy the Jewish guy sublet it to a to a
store and then raised the rents after
the church raised the rents on him
al Sharpton descended on this guy on
this store Freddy's fashion Mart and he
declared that white interlopers were
trying to take over the property even
though the property was actually owned
by a black church and all of that ended
with a crazy person trying to burn down
the place and killing several people hey
that he's just he's garbage okay he's
been garbage his entire his entire
career he has not once actually made
America a better place not once
that's who al Sharpton is that's who al
Sharpton was and what's amazing is how
al Sharpton was brought back into the
fold so for a long time al Sharpton was
out of the public eye now this is why I
say when people say the president Trump
has racially polarized the country
President Trump has not calmed racial
tensions in the country that is for sure
his commentary is not helpful but if you
want to talk about rising racial
polarization in America Barack Obama was
responsible for a lot of it he
absolutely was Barack Obama came into
office on a wave of enthusiasm for the
idea that he and his very personal was
going to help bridge gaps between black
and white that he was going to help he
was going to help conciliate the
conflict of a race that has ripped our
country for hundreds of years I mean
that was his promise right we're not
black were not white were the United
States
we're not red States when I blue states
that was his routine and then he came
into office and one of the first things
that he did presumably in order to buy a
certain level of legitimacy with certain
activists is he brought into the fold
people like Al Sharpton
this is from The Wall Street Journal
circa 2010 quote Obama's new partner al
Sharpton Peter walleston writing with
his wavy bouffant and medallion
necklaces the Reverend
sharpton famously confronted government
officials on behalf of black Americans
now he has found a new role telling
black leaders to quiet their criticisms
and give the government a chance
President Barack Obama has turned to
Sharpton in recent weeks to answer
increasingly public criticism in the
black community over his economic policy
some black leaders are charging that the
nation's first african-american
president has failed to help black
communities hit hard by the downturn
leaving party strategists worried that
black Democrats will become dispirited
and skipped November's congressional
elections Sharpton has emerged as an
important part of the White House
response on his national radio program
he's directly rebutting the president's
critics arguing that mr. Obama is right
to craft policies aimed at lifting all
Americans rather than specifically
targeting blacks when recent on-air
fight with Tavis Smiley a prominent
talk-show host an Obama critic whose so
heated it has created a small sensation
among black leaders Sharpton told smiler
quote the president does not need to get
out there and do what we should be doing
he argued that expecting Obama to become
quote a black exponent of black views
was just stupid because it would create
fodder for conservatives looking to
defeat legislation that could ultimately
help blacks Sharpton said it was a
double standard for Tavis Smiley and
other critics to expect more from a
black president than they would demand
of a democratic white president The Wall
Street Journal reported at the time 2010
mr. Sharpton is an unlikely White House
partner given his racially polarizing
history and efforts by mr. Obama's 2008
campaign team to steer clear of the
civil rights leader but Sharpton could
help ensure that blacks remain energized
for November's election an important
task in a year that finds the Democratic
base to be less enthusiastic about
voting than our Republicans Sharpton had
been to the White House five times since
Obama took office Sharpton's radio
program has become a friendly place for
administration officials to address
black leaders Obama would Sharpton he
made Sharpton prominence again and then
Sharpton was given a show on MSNBC okay
that was Obama picking out a racially
polarizing and not just racially
polarizing a race-baiting garbage
human-like al Sharpton and revitalizing
his career and making him an important
person again a person that Peabody judge
has to visit in order to get the
blessing of the woke Pope over here
right yesterday he has to go get the
blessing of a guy who again does not
represent the black community al
Sharpton does not represent the black
community Jesse Jackson does not
represent the blue
community in fact I think it's fair to
say no one represents the black
community because when it comes to the
black community
everyone there is an individual just
like nobody represents the quote/unquote
white community or the Hispanic
community when people say that al
Sharpton is a black leader all I can say
is show me the size of his his support
base I'm not seeing it
but it was Obama who decided to bring
Sharpton back into the fold and make him
a thing again Randall Kennedy professor
at Harvard Law School was black I know
professor Kennedy I took one of his
classes when I was at Harvard Law School
and he and I disagree about nearly
everything but he's a reasonable human
being he wrote a piece in September 2011
for the New Republic called the Sharpton
Renaissance how the reverend's
reputation got refurbished quote there
was a time not long ago when the
dominant arbiters of public opinion
relegated Al Sharpton's the outskirts of
serious respectable discussion sure he
was a fixture on the ebony magazine list
of the top 100 black Americans sure
journalists called him when they need a
provocative quip sure Democratic Party
politicians courted him but the Rebbe
was unmistakeably relegated to the black
ghetto of celebrity journal and
celebrity activism no one thought to ask
his opinion regarding issues other than
those perceived as directly pertinent to
aggrieved blacks the deference accorded
by establishment bigwigs stem more from
fear of his ability to cause them
trouble than respect for his skill at
envisioning positive initiatives among
white opinion leaders he was widely seen
as the very embodiment of a race hustler
a living version of Reverend bacon the
demagogue that Tom Wolfe concocted in
his novel bonfire of the vanities
there was alas a basis for this negative
impression but now says Randall Kennedy
Sharpton has risen above the confines of
a strictly racial niche and emerged as a
person of far-flung and real influence
his prominence in the American
mainstream from his appearances on the
Sunday morning news network programs to
a favorable profile on 60 minutes a
laudatory cover in Newsweek and now his
own primetime show on MSNBC is partly by
intensive ambition persistence skill and
an apparent immunity to embarrassment
but it is also due in no small parts to
the sponsorship of President Obama and
this is what happened here
Obama was alienating Jesse Jackson and
he needed out Sharpton to close that gap
that's one of the things that happened
in 2008 Jackson didn't like Obama Obama
went to Sharpton since Obama's victory
says Randall
circa 2011 sharpton has not only been an
unequivocal cheerleader he's been a
vocal critic of blacks on the left who
complain about Obama's priorities
appointments and methods Sharpton is
acidly and repeatedly rebuked for
example Cornel West one of the
president's most esteemed
african-american detractors in that way
Sharpton performs the valuable service
to Obama of validating his racial
bonafide ease when West's have a smiling
at Maxine Waters among others draw into
question Obama's commitment to black
folk Sharpton is on-hand to refute them
the president has rewarded Sharpton
handsomely for his services when seeking
to display attentiveness to black
concerns he includes Sharpton among the
leaders he purportedly consults he has
invited Sharpton to the White House for
numerous events including his birthday
bash the president's patronage has
played a key role in the Renaissance of
Sharpton's public image so as we say
when it comes to racial polarization in
the United States the media didn't take
any notice of this Randall Kennedy did
the Wall Street Journal did at the time
but it was Obama who restored one of the
great race-baiting grifters in American
history to a point of central contention
and now apparently it is a point of hot
controversy to criticize al Sharpton and
point out exactly what Al Sharpton is if
Democrats want this this is what
Democrats bought you want to know why
racial polarization has been growing in
this country it didn't start with
trumpet and ain't gonna end with Trump
so long as the media continued to
rehabilitate pieces of crap like Al
Sharpton we'll get to more of this in
just one second Democrats defending
anything Trump opposes first let's talk
about how you can actually get food more
easily so right now my kitchen is under
construction that means we are ordering
out an awful lot and you know I got two
little kids I can't really at night
throw them in the car all the time and
take them to a restaurant very often the
best thing for me to do is call door -
door - connects you to your favorite
restaurants in your city ordering is
really easy you just use the door - app
and you choose what you want to eat and
a dashing will bring it to you anywhere
you are not only is the burger place you
love on tour - already over 300 10,000
other amazing restaurants are - tor -
connects you with door to door delivery
in over 3,300 cities all 50 states in
Canada ordered from your local go twos
choose from your favorite chains like
Chipotle Wendy's chick-fil-a Cheesecake
Factory you know pretty much all the
restaurants you want are gonna be on
tour - so stop worrying about dinner let
dinner come to you with door - right now
our listeners get an awesome deal five
bucks off your first order of fifteen
bucks or more when you download the door
-
and use promo code been remember to use
that promo clip been it's five bucks off
your first order when you download the
door - app from the App Store and enter
promo code been again that is promo code
been for five bucks off your first order
from door - go check them out right now
I'm relying on them heavily I promise
everything that it's it's really they
make your life a lot easier is what I'm
saying to you you get that great that
great deal again five bucks off your
first order from door - when you spend
15 bucks download that door - chef use
promo code dependent okay we'll get to
more of the media defending everything
in the world that President Trump
attacks in just one second first quick
reminder next month we're taking our
backstage show on the road for a special
one-night only event that's August 21st
at the beautiful Terrace Theatre in Long
Beach California me daily where God came
Jeremy boring Andrew Clavin the
execrable Michael moles will all be
there live will be talking politics pop
culture will be answering your questions
from the audience
tickets are on sale right this very
instant at daily wire comm slash
backstage including our limited VIP
packages that guarantee premium seating
photos meet and greets with each of us a
gift from me I'm shopping for it to say
I keep promising it but I keep
forgetting and more so head on over to
daily wire comm slash backstage get your
tickets today I will see you there also
please subscribe over at daily wired at
comments we mentioned earlier on the
show Media Matters and nasty left groups
like that are looking constantly to
knock us off the air attack our
advertisers go after us one of the ways
you can keep us on the air and make sure
that we can continue to bring you the
truth is by subscribing and becoming
part of the team when you spend ninety
nine bucks a year you get the annual
subscription which comes complete with
this the very greatest in all beverage
vessels look at that the leftist years
how to call tumblr magnificent go check
it out right now I promise you will
enjoy it we are the largest fastest core
and conservative podcast and radio show
in the nation
[Music]
you
okay so as I say the Democrats will
defend anything so long as president
Trump attacks it and that is why the
Democrats have come to to see Rasheeda
Talib and the rest of the squad as their
allies even though Rasheeda Talib is
blatantly anti-semitic even though
Rasheeda Talib is a terrible Congress
person she has a piece in The Washington
Post today called called well Trump
spews hate I continue to do my job
her job apparently involves helping to
sponsor resolutions in favor of
boycotting the State of Israel that
resolution by the way if it were carried
into effect it has no legal effect if it
were carried into effect it would
actually be illegal under federal law
because federal contractors are not
allowed to discriminate BDS is
discrimination
therefore if she were to legalize
discrimination it would be invalid
anyway she has a piece in The Washington
Post today talking about what a victim
she is because Trump has attacked her
it's so terrible but she she is standing
up for the truth and Democrats of course
are rallying around the the squad
they're rallying around anything that
President Trump opposes President Trump
could come out against cancer they would
rally around it he could come out
against diabetes and they'll be like you
know what let's abolish insulin it's
time man diabetes has to have its day
according to Rasheeda Talib he said the
values I hold dear are not in line with
those in my home state of Michigan
nothing could be further from the truth
we are grounded in the values of equity
justice respect for each other I was
elected to represent the city of Detroit
and Wayne County it's remarkable time in
our country's history when the president
is hindering our desire for universal
health care lower prescription drug
prices equity in education and stopping
the for-profit schemes that hurt
children and communities such as mine
with every hate fuel tweet he gets us
off track as we try to hold him and his
reckless administration accountable
yada-yada yada-yada and of course the
democrats continue to rally around now
al Sharpton initiated Talib and I guess
the greatness of how Baltimore has been
run that's been pretty fantastic so
instead of actually instead of actually
tackling what Trump is saying about
Baltimore for example or explaining the
president Trump doesn't have any
solutions for Baltimore he's just
mouthing off which is actually what
happened there or that the squad are too
radical what you Nancy Pelosi was trying
to say two weeks ago instead the media
have decided to rally around the Trump
is a racist narrative because they're
they're really familiar with it it's
like an old
standby there's certain quarterbacks you
know they're gonna call a run on a
particular play because they're
uncomfortable with the throw well that
is the Democrats at this point and that
is the media they're uncomfortable with
throwing the ball down the field you
know risking it all on policy or on a
rational conversation instead they're
just gonna go with the run which may
gain them a couple of yards in a pile of
dust and the run is racism
so CNN's Don Lemon yesterday he talked
to a black pastor who met with President
Trump so Trump met with a bunch of
pastors from the inner city and Don
Lemon said to this black pastor is it
godly how Trump attacks people of color
I'm I definitely recall Don Lemon asking
Barack Obama whether it was godly for
the Reverend Al Sharpton to be visiting
the White House after you know inciting
a couple of riots allegedly here is here
is Don Lemon though doing this routine
you know I know it's hard for you you
think it's hard to believe that Trump is
racist but he's repeatedly used racially
charged language he consistently attacks
black and brown elected leaders he does
not just attack black people he attack
anybody and you do it as a man of faith
as a Christian you're saying he attacks
anyone it sounds like you're condoning
attacks is that Christian Lee or godly
I'm just stating a statement of fact I'm
not condoning anything I'm stating a
statement of fact President Trump does
not pick the people he attacks because
of color he attacks anybody he feels
needed there's a hundred percent truth
but I love Don Lemon now doing this
religious routine well you know you know
isn't it is it godly when he attacks
people I don't know it was godly when
Barack Obama decided that he was going
to slander the officers of Cambridge
Massachusetts was a godly when he
welcomed al Sharpton back into the good
graces of American society after al
Sharpton had helped set set off racial
conflicts conflagrations on repeated
occasions don't worry guys the media
isn't biased you won't know how the
media isn't biased because CNN had a
panel yesterday talking about Baltimore
and someone points it out he didn't
Bernie like rip Baltimore in 2015 and
talked about how it was a third world
country and everyone agrees no it's
totally different cuz that was Bernie
man and Bernie's just a good guy but
Trump's a bad guys when Trump rips
Baltimore totally different senator I'm
sorry Jan let me let me show you this
tweet from President Trump he says crazy
Bernie Sanders recently equated the city
of Baltimore to a
third-world country based on that
statement I assume that Bernie must now
be labeled a racist just as a Republican
would if you use that term in standard
but there is a difference of course and
look I think everybody should be focused
on helping people in the inner city of
Baltimore get the help they need people
would like more jobs they'd like health
care they'd like all sorts of benefits
that the government could certainly
support but there is a commonality and a
pattern with President Trump here and I
think that's important context oh you
see there's a difference no we're not
going to explain the difference we're
just gonna say that there is a
difference and then everybody's sort of
just accepts it as wrote that there's a
difference that when Trump says that
Baltimore's a bad place and when Bernie
Sanders the book says that Baltimore is
a bad place totally totally different
they mean two totally different things
and this is all of course pushing a
particular narrative Trevor Noah who
again is in this running gun battle for
unfunniest person in America
occasionally he's funny so he is still
running well behind Samantha be who I
think has his run away I mean she's like
the Secretariat of unfunny nasaan
late-night TV but Trevor Noah says you
don't have to be a genius to know what
Trump means when he talks about
Baltimore really spell it out for me
Trevor this language is part of a
pattern right president Trump always
uses the word infestation when talking
about people of color almost always uses
it he said illegal immigrants are
infesting America said Congressman John
Lewis's Atlanta district is
crime-infested and that the squad must
go back to their crime infested
countries like you don't need to be a
genius to see what Trump is implying cuz
he's not a subtle person okay so um
here's the thing as I said yesterday he
called New Hampshire drug-infested New
Hampshire is whiter than any blank piece
of paper you can find it is that there
are 1.1 percent of the population of New
Hampshire is black so when you said it
was drug infested was he talking about
black people at what what did that mean
all of this is meant to drive the
narrative and the narrative is that
black people are under threat Democrats
want to portray that narrative despite
the fact that we have record black
unemployment despite the fact that
blacks in the last several election
cycles have outpaced their percentage of
the population in terms of the voting
population what they want is for black
people to feel under threats that black
people turn out and vote against
President Trump duplicating the Obama
2012 coalition rather than their turnout
in 2008 alone Charlemagne the God he was
one of the people on MSNBC pushing this
I mean you want to talk about over the
top here's over the top
what the president has done over the
last two years is that enough to get
black voters motivated again to go out
and vote for him in a big way I mean if
they know it I know that they should
because you know if America is in danger
like who you think is gonna be impacted
the most
by whatever racist policies you know
whatever policies that oppress whatever
policies that marginalized like who's
next to be in concentration camps in
America it's not gonna be white people I
don't think so if we if we if we know
what's good for us we will definitely go
out there and vote but I don't think
it's anything wrong with making sure
that the Democrats have a black agenda
Charlamagne tha God says that this is
the narrative that folks are seeking to
push and why don't people trust the
media because this narrative is not true
okay this narrative that President Trump
is attacking Al Sharpton he sharpens
black or attacking Baltimore because
Baltimore is a largely black city it's
not true Trump attacks anybody who
annoys him he does it all the time I
also don't believe the media because the
media are basically willing to say
anything about anybody so for example
the media have been pushing for now
about a week this idea then that Mitch
McConnell cocaine Mitch is actually
Moscow Mitch he's actually working for
the Russians why well after the Muller
hearings which were a giant dud for the
Democrats I mean a giant fail for the
Democrats they immediately pretended
that they were shocked to find that the
Russians had been hacking the election
had been involved in hacking during the
election and that they were involved in
trying to manipulate people during the
election and so then they took a bill
that passed that they passed with only
one Republican vote in the house and
they tried to have it declared into law
in the Senate by Unanimous Consent and
Republicans said no Mitch McConnell said
no sorry this was a controversial bill
it was a controversial controversial
bill because usually voting provisions
in the United States are left to the
states we've already spent something
like 340 billion dollars on election
security going into upcoming elections
that was passed by a Republican Senate
okay and Mitch McConnell for holding up
a bill that has a lot of specifics that
are controversial including the use of
paper mandated paper ballots as backups
for example there's also mandated
particular uses of federal authority
over state elections Republicans
generally have opposed this because how
state elections are run is generally up
to States not up to the federal
government in any case Mitch McConnell
was called Moscow Mitch by Joe
Scarborough and then this became a
that he's actually attempting to shield
he's actually attempting to shield the
Russians that the Russians can continue
interfering in our elections right now
trending on twitter is hashtag Moscow
mich nicht reason it's just ridiculous
I'm sorry it's ridiculous everybody
knows this is ridiculous who has half a
brain
here's Mountain McConnell defending
himself in the White House regardless of
which way the political winds were
blowing I have consistently treated
Russia like the threat that it is even
under a Republican administration I
spoke out when I was afraid the US
wasn't doing enough to stop the erosion
of democracy and rule of law in Russia
so mr. friend I don't normally take the
time to respond to critics in the media
when they have no clue what they're
talking about but this modern-day
McCarthyism is toxic and damaging
because of the way it warps our entire
public discourse okay and that of course
is exactly right it is ridiculous do you
really think that Mitch McConnell is a
Russian tool or the Mitch McConnell is
ignoring election security because it
some fealty to Trump it's ridiculous
again this bill only passed the house
with one Republican vote it was not
really noticed because Democrats passed
it and nobody assumed it was going
anywhere Democrats then presented it as
though it was some sort of bipartisan
achievement and then I look at that
Mitch McConnell standing in the way
standing in the way of election progress
running state elections is the
responsibility of states and localities
this is true under the Constitution and
this has always been McConnell's
position which is why I can't I can't
find her I've asked Melton multiple
Republican senators about this not one
Republican senator opposes McConnell on
this not one sorry McConnell supporter
was 380 million not billion in aid to
election security funding that passed
Congress just a few months ago he
supported the bipartisan Senate
Intelligence Committee investigation
into election interference that produced
an alarming public report last week this
is exactly like when Democrats claim
there's a crisis and then they pass and
then they propose like a trillion dollar
bill that doesn't solve the crisis
Republicans oppose it and then Democrats
say the Republicans refuse to
acknowledge the crisis it's exactly the
sort of the same sort of idiotic virtue
signal and you see with the green New
Deal climate change we're all
I in 10 years and if you don't pass this
meaningless bill and vote for it you're
a bad person then it comes up for a vote
not a single Democrat votes for it but
the media been touting this the media
been touting this Moscow much nonsense
pretending that it's real it is not real
it never was real and yet they suggest
that we are supposed to apparently
respect their take on it somehow yeah I
have my doubts
hey meanwhile going into the debates
tonight first first round of the second
debates it's hard to figure out to term
these things because now there are 83
different rounds of debates but it's the
first round of the second debates
tonight and it features Elizabeth Warren
and beta ho and Bernie Sanders and bit
in beta
who else done it boo to judge boo judges
in the - okay so it's the all white
people debate the only question about
the debate tonight is whether Bernie
Sanders is able to defend himself
against Elizabeth Warren Warren has been
making slow but steady gains the only
way that one of them becomes a
challenger to Biden is if one of them
loses this is Highlander now only one
can only one can reign so we will see if
there is any sort of conflict because
here's the facts according to new polls
Joe Biden has restored his lead so it
seemed after the last debates that he
was starting to sink and then Joe Biden
went back to his original strategy which
was disappear and let the other
Democrats act like idiots and he started
to gain in the polls again according to
new Emerson poll he's back on top at 33
percent 13 points ahead of Bernie
Sanders who's at 20% Warren at 14%
Sanders has gained five points since
Emerson's last survey Kamala Harris has
fallen four points which there was a
reversion to the mean for Kamala Harris
she had a big bump and then she started
to drop again she was not able to build
on that momentum because she is
mechanical Nate silver yesterday the
pollster compared her to Mitt Romney and
that I think is kind of fair like she
sort of checks a lot of boxes for
Democrats but she doesn't enthuse anyone
the only other candidates about 3% were
mayor Pete Budaj at 6% in bado at four
again I am astonished by the amount of
media attention Budaj edge has gotten to
receive 6% in these polls who to judge
does not have apparently any breakaway
quality that has allowed him to climb he
sort of reached his high point a couple
months ago and it's been again reversion
to the mean ever since morning consults
also has a survey survey today that
shows by
at the top with 33% Sanders is again
seconds in this survey so that's a bit
consistent with 18% and Warren at 13 and
Harris at 12 so Sanders is showing a
little bit more durability than I
thought he would at this point I thought
he was gonna slide into oblivion we will
see tonight if Elizabeth Warren is able
to put the hit on him and knock him down
a couple of pegs that's what she needs
to do because both Warren and Sanders
are not going to survive the final round
it will be one or the other okay time
for some things I like and then a quick
thing that I hate okay things that I
like so you want to talk about climate
change let's talk about climate change
so a lot of folks on the Left are very
focused in on climate change as a key
and important issue I'm not averse to
discussing climate change is the key an
important issue if we do so in a
rational way what I'm not going to do is
humor the idea that the world will be on
fire by 2100 that all of the coasts will
be underwater
that we are all going to die by 2100 if
we don't do anything to stop climate
change in the next 12 years I do not buy
it I think that there are mitigation
efforts that can be made I think there
are things like geoengineering that can
be done I think that there has been talk
and there should be more talk of
deregulation of the nuclear power
industry which is one of the easiest
ways of producing energy at
cost-effective method without increasing
carbon emissions but in order to assess
the actual damage you have to go about
it in a rational way there's a great
book out by William Nordhaus from 2013
it's called the climate casino talking
about the risks of climate change and
trying to assess what those risks are
because very often what you hear from
the left is this definitive here is
exactly what's going to happen and the
answer is you don't know now it is quite
possible that something bad is going to
happen in the future there are tipping
points in the environment as William
Nordhaus Nobel Prize winner in economics
last year talks about their tipping
points and we're not sure where the
tipping points are where for example the
ice caps start to melt a lot faster than
they wore if you reach a certain level
of carbon dioxide in the atmosphere
there's talk about a certain level of
ocean acidification that is unable to be
recovered from or sea level rises over
the course of the next 500 years you
have to sort of number one determine
time frame number two you have to
determine what exactly the modeling
shows about the time frame so they're
models that show that by 2100 that'll be
warming about two degrees Celsius which
is about 6 degrees Fahrenheit let's see
yeah about 4 degrees Fahrenheit rather
or it could be all the way up to 6
degrees Celsius sorry it could yes it
could
up to six degrees Celsius which of
course would be the upper end modeling
it's pretty unlikely that happens but it
is possible the best kind of average
scenario is three degrees Celsius by the
end of the century which would mean six
degrees Fahrenheit which would be a
problem but it would not mean that ocean
levels rise by thirty or forty feet as
people keep saying right this book does
a good job of breaking down what exactly
are the rewards and the risks over time
he suggests a carbon tax as a
possibility I think it's gonna be very
difficult to implement a carbon tax on a
global scale which is what you would
need in order to actually affect climate
change in any real way otherwise what
you get is a serious free-rider problem
where the United States imposes a carbon
tax like Europe has and then starts
importing oil from other places and also
China and India just keep reducing
carbon emissions to an extraordinary
extent the fact is that as Nordhaus
points out also whatever future problems
we're going to deal with we're also
gonna be dealing with an economy that is
completely different by 2100 the centers
of power are going to shift in the in
the world economy back in - back in 1901
anyone who predicted that China was
going to be a world economic power or
that Russia was going to have fade it
into a bled oblivion you can't predict
what's gonna happen in the economy this
book does a good job of trying to
reasonably lay out the case for what
exactly is happening with climate change
what the economic costs are going to be
of climate change how we assess those
what we should do about it what we can
do about it as I've said I think there
needs to be talk about geoengineering I
think there needs to be talked about
building sea walls and mitigation I
think that there should be talk about
international agreements but those
international agreements have to have
teeth and if those international
agreements are not reachable then
destroying the United States economy so
that China and India can catch up with
us and free ride off of our own
willingness to our economy seems
like a very very bad idea this is why
when people say there are easy solutions
to climate change the answer is yes if
you could wave a magic wand I'm sure
there would be but in a world populated
by real governments and real people not
so much
the Paris climate Accords were a
complete waste of time mainly because
nobody was abiding by the Paris climate
Accord is the number one reduction in
carbon emissions by country has happened
in the United States since the Paris
climate Accord and since they pull out
from the Paris
in accord by President Trump so that
international agreement didn't mean
anything China signed and then kept
emitting like nobody's business
so again I think the book is well worth
reading the climate casino risk
uncertainty and economics for a warming
world by William Nordhaus an actual
reasonable take on the issue as opposed
to the climate catastrophe at astrov
thinking you see so often okay time for
a quick thing that I hate
okay so Ted Cruz was at LAX and there is
this new thing on the Left where if you
are if you see a Republican in public
you are supposed to berate this
Republican in public this gives you some
sort of virtue signaling points it is
stupid and irritating it makes the
country a worse place if you want to go
to his office and protest do it if you
want to sponsor some sort of rally
outside the Capitol building do it if
you want to harass public officials in a
public place simply because they happen
to be standing around in the airport
this makes you a jackass I wouldn't do
this to any Democrat I don't think many
Republicans would frankly and if they
did I think would be a nasty thing if
you're not asking him a legitimate
question if you're not a journalist
who's trying to get an answer for
example if you're just there to bother
him and yell at him then this makes you
a bad person and it makes the country a
worse place because we at least have to
have common spaces that we can share if
I have to bring security with me every
time I go to the airport because I'm
afraid somebody's gonna punch me in the
face that doesn't make for a better
country and if I'm there with my wife
and kids in a public place and you're a
costing me to scream at me this fairly
definitionally makes you a bad person
here's a little bit of the table
[Music]
we're standing there shouting at Ted
Cruz Americans will not be silenced
there's a bunch of them then it turns
into like a quick social media mob
everybody bringing their cameras whoa
look at us look at our courage Americans
no one silencing you you're standing
there screaming in the middle of an
airport like jackass now there's Ted
Cruz being very polite because this is
what Ted does in public you know the
fact that none of these people wanted to
have a conversation or discussion they
just want to yell at Ted Cruz
demonstrates this is all virtue
signaling garbage I want to make the
country a worse place this is a pretty
good way of doing it all right we will
be back here later today with two
additional hours of content so otherwise
we'll see you here tomorrow to recap
those Democratic debates i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Savitz audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
hey everyone its Andrew clave and host
of the Andrew Clavin show politics
corrupts but identity politics corrupts
absolutely
Trump has broken through that evil
racist system not politely I admit more
like The Incredible Hulk walking through
a wall the question is now that the wall
is down will the rest of us have the
courage to run free we'll talk about it
on the Andrew Clavin show I'm Andrew
Clavin